-Did you know dad had affairs?
-Oh, for sure.
-How?
-You could just tell.
Lisa told me she saw him
kissing a white woman once.
-Why did I have no idea?
Why am I the last to know?
-'Cause you love them
too much.
Enemies see each other better
than friends.
-The hell did you give her?
-It's oxycodone.
What? Knocks 'em right out.
-You gave her opioids to sleep?
-Yeah. You ever seen
a heroin addict?
Those guys take naps
standing up.
-It's dangerous.
-Look, I'm keeping an eye
on her.
I'm a doctor.
-So am I.
-Right. Maybe if we need
to revive a sentence.
-We're back here
with Sterling K. Brown.
That was a clip
from "American Fiction"
with the great Jeffrey Wright.
-Yes.
Amazing.
-A couple of things.
One, I just assumed,
based on the quality of his work
over the years,
so consistently excellent,
Jeffrey been nominated
for an Oscar before.
This is his first nomination.
-His first nomination.
-Even cooler,
this is the first time
two Black actors
have been nominated for lead
and supporting in the same film.
-Isn't that crazy?
-That's crazy and wonderful.
-Yeah, like, honestly, I've been
a part of a couple of firsts,
and it's 2024, and I was like,
this has happened already,
hasn't it?
It's like first time?
Alright, that's cool.
-It's fun to be the first.
It should have happened earlier,
but I guess it's nice to be --
-Not too bad.
-Speaking of fun,
it did seem like this is a movie
that takes
on a lot of weighty subjects,
but it also feels like a film
where the cast --
because, I don't know,
it's funny
how it approaches everything.
It seemed like you were
all having
a very good time with it.
-Well, we had an absolute blast.
I mean, we talk about
a lot of different things
in terms of representation
and sort of the narrow milieu
in terms of what Black people
are often seen in
and trying to expand
the breadth of representation,
but at the same time,
like it's really,
really, really funny.
And when you're
having fun on set --
I'm working with my idols
with Leslie Uggams
and Jeffrey Wright,
Erika Alexander,
Tracee Ellis Ross,
and I just get a chance
to be silly and fun.
I'm normally the dude who has
to hold [bleep] together,
and in this one,
I'm a bit of a mess,
and you're like,
we got to deal with Cliff.
So it's fun to sort of occupy
that space.
And we all had a blast.
-Yeah, it was nice
to actually get
to see you as the sibling
who's a mess.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You had to do the heavy work.
-Randall had to hold it
together for a long time.
Now Cliff is just like,
I don't know.
-I want to talk to you
about a piece of work that,
based on what you've said,
you've never been asked about
on television before --
a role that I don't think
anybody -- when we talk
about representation
and the breadth of the roles
you're offered.
-Talk to me.
-You got to play Sia
in a Lonely Island video.
-I really did.
-This was -- Yeah.
-It was so much fun.
Andy came up to me.
I shot an episode of "Nine-Nine"
and he's like, hey, man,
would you want to come
and do this Lonely Island thing?
You get to play Sia.
And I was like,
how does that work?
And he's like, well,
I'll show you.
You're going to lip sync
all of her stuff.
And I was like, just -- it's
called "Silk Robes and Kimonos."
And I was like,
this sounds really dumb
and delightful.
-Yeah.
-Sign me up.
-By the way, dumb and delightful
describes everything
they've ever done.
Now, this is from
the wonderful Netflix.
I don't even call it --
I guess short.
I don't even know
how you would describe
"Bash Brothers" --
-"Bash Brothers."
-Yeah, I highly recommend
watching it.
But here, just for casting,
I would say the craziest thing
is you play Sia,
but then Andy plays
Jose Canseco and Akiva Schaffer
plays Mark McGuire.
-Yeah, it's all crazy.
-Nobody's playing
who they should.
-No.
-But you know what?
You guys are all in the pocket.
Let's take a look
at a quick clip.
-Oh, man.
-♪ Silk robes and kimonos ♪
♪ Silk robes and kimonos ♪
♪ Change outta
your own clothes ♪
♪ These athletic days,
but oh, those... ♪
-♪ Oakland Nights ♪
-It's really good.
It's really good.
-[ Laughs ]
-That was fun. Oh, man.
-Watching it,
it's a real, you know --
to casting directors everywhere,
just open your heart and your
mind when you're casting.
-You know what I'm saying?
Don't be so narrow.
Open your mind.
-The funniest thing was they
said we can only show 10 seconds
of the clip
because of music licensing.
And I'm like,
who's coming to get the money?
[Bleep] Samberg?
Is Samberg going to call up
and be like, "Hey, that was more
than a 10 seconds."
That's a good Samberg.
You're good.
-I do a very good --
Yeah, but will they ever
cast me as Samberg?
No, no, he's going to do it.
Uh, what a delight
to have you back.
Congratulations on everything.
-It's a pleasure, man.
Thank you so much.
-Good luck out there.
-Thank you, sir.
-The hard part's over.
Sterling K. Brown, everyone.
"American Fiction"
in theater now.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Melissa Rauch.